in peru about 10 million
people lack
basic water and sewage services do not have
access to drinking water for
human consumption with
fog catchers we are turning mist into water
[Music]
I am abel cruz gutiérrez president of the
movement organization  Peruvian without water
and we are creating this
system called mist catchers
a trap and speak is a system
composed of a nylon mesh that
can capture the micro droplets of water
in this mist that is floating
in the air
when the wind drags  all this the
micro drops that exist in the mist
collide with the mesh and this morning it
begins to condense and begins to
fall by its own gravity to the
gutter
from there it goes to a container and there
the water can be stored
at level  country we have 14 projects that
are working effectively
180 families are going to have their water all
between 20 and 30 thousand people are
taking advantage of these systems  emas today
in all of peru
a trapani to capture from 200 to 400
liters of water a day this water is used
to irrigate the plants for the
consumption of the animals to bathe to
wash utensils and to make orchards
family farming in small  scale
but we are going to put some filters on each
trap and that water is going to be for
human consumption that is the real idea and
what comes after this great
project
crystal clear water
in winter you can see the
mist one meter away  distance and that's
water that's water
if we don't put in the fog catchers they are
evaporated it returns to the sea no
this is a personal satisfaction for
me to know how we could solve and
we can help families who see
this alternative to solve the
lack of water
[Music  ]